with 14 million people mumbai is india's
financial hub and home to bollywood
and then from there
down south to some of the most stunning
coastal line anywhere in the world famed
for its fish it's home of the spices
it's where the spices originated from
i'm completing my culinary adventure of
india in the south it's famous for its
fish curries and unique spices
india produces over half the world's
supply
but i'm uneasy because south india is
also a hotbed of vegetarianism
two-fifths of indians are vegetarians
and half regularly eat a veggie diet
personally i'm a rampant carnivore and
vegetarian holier-than-thou attitudes
wind me up
captain madras please
welcome to mumbai thank you very much
already within the first two minutes
just seemed crazy
i mean everyone's a thousand mile an
hour
[Music]
look at that the most amazing indian
wedding
beautiful
absolutely starving
i'm meant to be rendezvousing with a
culinary expert
right captain mcgrath
rasmus
no chicken anywhere
i'm meeting rashmi yuday singh
she's in his top food critic and wrote
the country's very first restaurant
guide
rashmi hey
how are you darling
nice to see you
thank you lovely to see you you look
wonderful thank you and you look really
wonderful but you look a little hungry
you know i'm very hungry all i want
is butter chicken this is a pure
vegetarian restaurant the district is
pure vegetarian even if you want to rent
an apartment garden right
i know there's a lot of veggies in india
but a whole town
they're convinced vegetarianism can
combat the evils of modern life
what is it with meat eaters why are you
so antsy eating so much of chunks of
meat and foie gras and all that
we believe that that is what is
responsible
for your bad temper eating meat makes
you bad tempers
what load of bollocks unlike all that
stuff you eat this is actually good for
your spirit your emotions your feelings
will give you calm it will relax you
meat doesn't make me angry it makes me
excited just calm down let's get you
something to eat please then we'll talk
about our south indian mission yeah
let's okay
repeat after me promise promise to try
to try the vegetarian food seriously i i
promise i will
try vegetarian food you can open mine
with an open mind to show me what's out
there rashmi's ordered me the most
popular veggie meal in india
italy samba and roll dosa pancake
what's that a lamb shake isn't that
beautiful where's the light bulb we buy
things like that at the flea market in
london do you have a clothes what is
that
first i'm eating the idlis in a spicy
samba soup
the texture's like a like a sort of warm
sort of
texture's like a warm scone
it's nice
yeah i like that it's moorish it's
lovely okay lovely
nice you have an open mind and you
enjoyed it definitely
against my better judgment i've asked
rashmi's advice on where to find great
vegetarian food
she has a radical suggestion
you are going to visit
an ashram
a what an ashram
spiritual retreat you are going to go
and live there
with monks there's a lot of fabulous
vegetarian food there i'm not spending
all week
and my last
sort of
exciting week as a vegetarian no chance
now i'm going now
the whole week
no you're going to go back
with a journey not just to india but
into yourself i am not [ __ ] amy
winehouse's husband
i'm not checking into rehab
you're not checking in rehab you're
going to find yourself you are in our
country you are our guest you are like
god
the god in me salutes the god of you
have a great time good lord be with you
the lord jesus and call me if you need
me uh yes
absolutely
[Music]
i've heard his cooking is the best in
the state
it's not the kind of transport expected
to use to get around no
people always have this idea being holy
means being impractical yes
yeah
that's right
i have a wife and 1 million
children guru's ashram is the aisha
center it gets over 700 000 visitors a
year
he's a popular maharishi and he's
looking a bit more serious now
i'm very excited to be here
more nervous than excited
i'm never gone two days of my life
without eating meat your system is
essentially designed
to handle vegetarian diet right if you
eat according to that
it it handles food effortlessly yes
every human experience has a chemical
basis in the system right so if you want
to create the right kind of chemistry
there are various things that one can do
yes one of the things is food if you
create a chemistry of blissfulness
that's how you are all the time that's
impossible
i'm not going to argue in your temple
that's for sure i'm dying to see the
kitchens let's go thank you
so the guru reckons being vegetarian
makes you a joyful karma person
if that's true then these kitchens must
be amongst the happiest places on earth
the size of this place wow
it's a veggie
hangout look at those vegetables are
they grown are they grown here
a bit of it that's incredible okay
and here are the lychees
i'd love one please thank you how long
are you here for um
for a while
you're baking the fundamental rule
nobody ever eats in the kitchen before
the food is being offered to everybody
they never eat you can't eat around food
we're always picking in kitchens no
fancy a cucumber
fancy eliji
you gave me it got me into trouble
we're not allowed to eat in the kitchen
how many meals would you be cooking for
today seven thousand
vegetarian meals well that breaks my
heart
the 70 chefs are mostly unpaid
volunteers who work seven days on the
truck feeding visitors to the ashram
where's the meat section
the meat is here
this is the meat so what is this section
they are making a special type of
chapati seven thousand in for dinner
tonight and look how calm it is how come
the kitchen's so calm
because they're not eating meat right
because this is the heron's kitchen
heaven's kitchen not hell's kitchen
i like that
the guru's disciples eat in a communal
dining hall in total silence
men and women sit in separate lines
tonight's menu is a raw salad of red
cabbage and sweet corn tomato chutney
with lentils and cottage cheese
it's not exactly silver service
eating in silence isn't easy for someone
like me fortunately i've made a new
friend you can even keep your feet to
the sidelines that's fine i'll try and
cross the
card
another way just stretch both your legs
out yes
and sit like this
this is called grandmother's style
grandmother's side
it's incredible i feel so bad i can't
cross my legs
there notice if you uh the kind of food
that you eat also makes the body loose
and flexible as well so you're saying if
i become a vegetarian my body will
become a lot more veg a lot more
flexible possibilities
i can't
i can sit down i can't get to my food
you can just hold your certain of course
thank you
food is actually delicious what amazes
me
is not just the level integrity but the
volume of what they cook for
because it's done with such precision
you ever ask for more
yesterday was a surprise but i've not
been turned into a veggie disciple yet
[Music]
we've not had breakfast yet
the guru is cooking his speciality
the popular masala dosa is a pancake
made with dal and rice batter
that smells good
smells very good smiley fermented
that's the potato
it's an art to get the dosa right
because you have to ferment it to
exactly the right proportions
that's delicious
very crispy
see this is a pepper curry you just try
a little bit of it the pepper comes
straight from our backyard
it's organically grown thank you try
this and see it could be a little spicy
for you
yeah no i like that
i've been won over by the delicious food
but i'm not yet convinced by the guru's
reasoning
for me
a vegetable a vegetable is as alive
as a chicken or a lamb or whatever else
wrong it is not wrong are you saying
that a carrot has the same feelings as a
chicken that's not the point feelings
does not mean emotions they are
sensitive to life around them yes you
understand but you killed it you pulled
it from the ground you pulled it from
the ground but it's not dead
if you plant it it'll grow you take such
a high moral ground in terms of
no meat eating whatsoever food is not a
morality
food is a question of well-being so you
saying that i would be happier
for the second half of my life without
eating meat
you will be calmer
and more more at ease but i am calm
i am
i don't think the world thinks so
about your calmness you wouldn't know
you don't have any televisions here
[Laughter]
let's agree to disagree yes
spud
potato love it thank you
have a lovely breakfast thank you
it's taken a long time but you heard it
here first
i'm calling a ceasefire with vegetarians
if you're ever thinking of going
vegetarian then
get to an ashram quickly because
that's the confirmation
of how good it can be
but he is [ __ ] nuts i think he's
gesticulating much less than yesterday
don't you notice that
his body movements are little
first of all i'm definitely more chilled
out there's no ways about that um
yeah it has been an experience
you